This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In South Liverpool, there's a neighborhood called Granby. It used to be one of the most vibrant and diverse neighborhoods in the UK. It had a busy main street lined with shops and cafes. But by 2012, when an architect named Louis Jones first visited, most of the houses were unoccupied. So, you know, a couple of hundred houses, but only about 10 or 12 people still living there. the rest of the house is all empty.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马斯。在利物浦南部，有一个叫格兰比的街区。它曾经是英国最具活力和多元化的街区之一。这里曾有一条挂满商店和咖啡馆的繁华主街。但到了2012年，当一位名叫路易斯·琼斯的建筑师第一次来访时，大多数房子都无人居住。你知道的，几百栋房子里只有大约10到12个人还在那里生活，其余的房子全空着。
Granby had suffered through decades of unemployment, aggressive policing, and failed redevelopment schemes. And over time, the neighborhood had hollowed out. That's 99PI senior editor, Delaney Hall. The local government had forced residents to sell their homes and then boarded them up. But before the authorities sealed each house, they gutted it. They'd strip everything out.
格兰比经历了数十年的失业、强力治安和失败的重建计划。随着时间的推移，这个街区被掏空了。这是99PI的高级编辑德兰妮·霍尔。当地政府曾迫使居民卖掉房屋，然后将它们用木板封起来。但在当局封锁每栋房子之前，他们会将其内部拆空。他们会剥离掉所有东西。
They'd strip out the copper, the lead, everything that was seen to have an economic value, but also everything that would enable someone to live there, the toilets, the kind of infrastructure. And that was to prevent people from squatting in those houses after they'd been emptied out. And after stripping the houses and boarding up the windows, the government would place a sign on the front, reading.
他们会剥离铜、铅以及所有被认为具有经济价值的东西，还有所有能让人生存的东西，比如马桶和各种基础设施。这是为了防止人们在房屋被清空后非法侵占。在剥离了房屋并用木板封住窗户后，政府会在正门贴上一块牌子，上面写着。
All items of value have been removed from this property. And, you know, it's quite a provocation when every single house on the street says on it, no items of value in this house. Of course, the government meant materials like copper and lead. But there are other kinds of value embedded in a home. There's the skill it took to build it and the years of life that happened inside of it and the community that grew up around it. And what happened next in Granby would prove the signs wrong.
本物业所有有价值的物品均已被搬走。你知道的，当街上的每一栋房子都写着“此房屋内无有价物品”时，这是一种相当大的挑衅。当然，政府指的是铜和铅等材料。但房屋中还蕴含着其他价值。包括建造它所需的技能、其中度过的岁月，以及围绕它成长起来的社区。接下来在格兰比发生的事情将证明这些告示是错的。
A small group of residents basically refused. to leave the neighborhood. Little by little, they began clearing trash from the empty lots, planting community gardens, and painting the boarded-up houses in bright colors. Eventually, this band of holdouts formed a community land trust, or a CLT. Their goal was to take ownership of the empty houses and bring people back to the neighborhood. They raised money through a patchwork of small grants, and then they realized it might be useful to have some folks on board who knew how to design and build stuff, which is how Lewis got involved.
一小群居民基本上拒绝离开这个街区。他们一点一点地开始清理空地上的垃圾、种植社区花园，并用鲜艳的颜色粉刷用木板封住的房子。最终，这群坚守者成立了一个社区土地信托，简称CLT。他们的目标是获得空置房屋的所有权，并把人们带回这个街区。他们通过零星的小额资助筹集资金，然后他们意识到，如果能有一些懂得设计和建造的人加入，可能会很有用，这就是路易斯参与进来的原因。
They wanted to renovate those houses, they wanted to provide those as affordable housing, they wanted to invite people who previously had lived in that neighbor but had to be moved away from it. They wanted to invite those people back in. Lewis is a part of a design collective called Assemble. And with Assemble's support,
他们想翻新这些房子，想把它们作为经济适用房提供出来，他们想邀请以前住在那个街区但不得不搬走的人回来。他们想把那些人请回来。路易斯是Assemble设计集体的一员。在Assemble的支持下，
the CLT advocated to the local government to stop demolishing the remaining homes. Then they worked together to renovate a hands handful of the old houses. As they pulled out materials that were too damaged to save, they started experimenting with the debris. Eventually, they set up a little backyard workshop with a local artist. And together, they figured out how to make something that they called Granby Rock.
CLT向当地政府呼吁，停止拆除剩下的房屋。然后他们合作翻新了几栋老房子。当他们拆除那些损坏严重而无法挽救的材料时，他们开始用这些碎片进行试验。最终，他们在当地艺术家的帮助下，在后院搭建了一个小型作坊。他们一起琢磨出了一种他们称之为“格兰比岩”的东西。
And it was basically a kind of rubble tarasso that we'd take all of the broken bricks and bits of slates and other kind of debris coming out of the renovation process. And we'd recast them as components. for these new decorative fireplaces and mantelpieces that we then put back into each house. Every chunk of Granby Rock was unique, swirled with color from the old bricks, and flecked with pieces of broken slate.
这基本上是一种水磨石废墟，我们收集翻新过程中产生的所有碎砖、碎石板和其他碎片。然后我们将它们重新铸造成这些新的装饰性壁炉和壁炉架的构件，再把它们安回到每栋房子里。每一块“格兰比岩”都是独一无二的，带有旧砖的漩涡状色彩，并点缀着碎石板。
Then it was poured into molds and polished smooth. Granby Rock fireplaces and countertops went into each of the renovated houses. It just felt important as part of kind of the process of reclaiming the narrative of these houses, of this neighborhood that actually valuing everything that was there was important. Over the next few years, dozens of properties in Granby were renovated and then offered as affordable housing, and slowly people started moving in.
然后将它倒入模具中并打磨光滑。“格兰比岩”壁炉和台面被安装到了每一栋翻新过的房子里。作为重新夺回这些房子和这个街区叙事过程的一部分，这感觉很重要，因为重视这里存在的一切是很重要的。在接下来的几年里，格兰比的几十处房产被翻新，并作为经济适用房推出，人们慢慢地开始搬进来。
New families prepared dinner on the countertops made from salvaged brick. They sat near fireplaces that were cast from the rubble of the house next door. They were living in a very real way with materials from the neighborhoods. complicated past. In the world of design, there's a term that's used for the practice of taking elements from older buildings and reusing them in new ones. It's called spolia. And what assembled did in Granby was a version of that.
新的家庭在由回收砖制成的台面上准备晚餐。他们坐在由隔壁房子的瓦砾铸造的壁炉旁。他们以非常真实的方式与这个街区复杂过去的材料共同生活。在设计界，有一个术语用来指代从旧建筑中提取元素并在新建筑中重复使用它们的做法。这被称为“spolia”（古建筑构件再利用）。Assemble在格兰比做的事情就是其中的一种版本。
The designers looked at the materials from the old houses, and they saw an opportunity to make something new. Reuse has always been an element of how humans build. We are endless recyclers, pulling. nails out of old burn timbers and cleaning and restacking used bricks and hauling stone from one building to the next. But with spolia, this reuse isn't just a matter of practicality. It also carries meaning. The old material has a history and using it in a new building is a way of acknowledging that what came before still matters. And that might be why spolia shows up in some of the world's
设计师们看着老房子的材料，看到了创造新事物的机会。重复利用一直是人类建造方式的一个要素。我们是不知疲倦的回收者，从旧的烧焦木材中拔出钉子，清洗并重新堆叠旧砖，把石头从一栋建筑运到另一栋。但对于spolia来说，这种重复利用不仅仅是实用性问题。它还承载着意义。旧材料有着一段历史，在新的建筑中使用它，是一种承认过去依然重要的方式。这也许就是为什么spolia会出现在世界上一些最著名的建筑中，
most famous architecture, places like the Hyac Sophia. Notre Dame and the great mosque of Cordoba, all Guse repurposed stonework. But to really understand Spolia, you have to go back to the place where the practice first became widespread. It happened when a civilization was in the middle of an existential crisis, and it started pulling apart the old world in order to build a new one. That civilization was the Roman Empire. That's funny. I was just thinking about the Roman Empire.
比如圣索菲亚大教堂、巴黎圣母院和科尔多瓦清真寺，它们都使用了重新利用的石雕。但要真正理解spolia，你必须回到这种做法首次广泛传播的地方。那发生在文明处于生存危机之中时，它开始拆解旧世界来建造新世界。那个文明就是罗马帝国。太逗了。我刚才正好在想罗马帝国。
Empire. At its peak, the Roman Empire controlled the entire Mediterranean world. It spanned Europe, North Africa, and Western Asia. The empire lasted for roughly five centuries. And nearly 2,000 years later, we are still arguing about its legacy. So my name is Dr. Emma Southern. I am a Roman historian. I am an ex-academic, and now I write books about how horrible the Romans were. Emma loves to hate the Romans. She has been obsessed ever since she first learned about them as a teenager. The thing that I love the most about them more than any other empire really is the complete disconnect between their image of themselves
帝国。在其鼎盛时期，罗马帝国控制了整个地中海世界。它横跨欧洲、北非和西亚。这个帝国持续了大约五个世纪。近两千年来，我们仍在争论它的遗产。我叫埃玛·索瑟恩博士。我是一名罗马历史学家。我曾是一名学者，现在我写书讲述罗马人有多糟糕。埃玛对罗马人又爱又恨。自从她十几岁时第一次了解他们以来，她就一直对他们着迷。比起其他任何帝国，我最喜欢他们的一点，真的是他们对自己的形象的认知，
as being the most rational, the most perfect, the peak of civilization, the best that humanity can be, combined with the actual reality of what their empire was, which was a horrifically violent machine, that chewed up land, it chewed up resources, and produced marble buildings and emperors. The Romans projected power through architecture. Emperors built enormous monuments to prove that they were rich and legitimate. Emperor Augustus famously claimed that he, quote, found Rome a city of brick and left it a city of marble. Hadrian built the pantheon. Trajan built his famous column. The Flavian emperors made the
认为自己是最理性、最完美、文明的顶峰、人类所能成为的最好状态，而这与他们的帝国的真实现实之间存在着彻底的脱节——那是一个极其暴力的机器，它吞噬土地、吞噬资源，并制造出大理石建筑和皇帝。罗马人通过建筑投射权力。皇帝们建造巨大的纪念碑来证明他们富有且合法。奥古斯都皇帝曾有一句名言，称他“发现了一个砖砌的罗马，却留下了一个大理石的罗马”。哈德良建造了万神殿。图拉真建造了他著名的圆柱。弗拉维王朝的皇帝们建造了
In fact, pretty much all the Roman emperors that were familiar with today are the ones who left behind something monumental. Because that was the whole point of building the monuments in the first place. The Romans were always thinking about the future. They were always imagining us, 2,000 years down the road, marveling at what they created. As soon as they can afford to build an expensive stone, they do build an expensive stone because they know it will last. and they're always producing for the generations in the future to make sure they will be remembered. The most expensive, durable, monumental stone to build with was marble, and Romans quarried it from all over their empire. They got green marble from Greece and red porphyry from Egypt.
事实上，今天我们熟悉的几乎所有罗马皇帝，都是那些留下了某种宏伟建筑的人。因为这正是当初建造纪念碑的全部意义所在。罗马人总是在考虑未来。他们总是在想象我们，在两千年后，惊叹于他们创造的东西。一旦他们有能力建造昂贵的石头建筑，他们就会建造昂贵的石头建筑，因为他们知道这会持久，而且他们总是在为未来的世代生产，以确保他们会被人们记住。最昂贵、最耐用、最宏伟的建筑石材是大理石，罗马人从他们帝国的各地开采大理石。他们从希腊获取绿色大理石，从埃及获取红色斑岩。
These Roman quarries were state-owned and they relied mostly on slave labor. They were located in hot, dry places and they were all overseen by the army. It was terrible backbreaking work. After mining the marble, the Romans shipped it across the Mediterranean and used it to build the kind of magnificent structures they became famous for. And that's how it went for many centuries. The Romans built monuments to show how awesome they were, using rare stone from far-flung places, and the message it conveyed was clear. Rome was eternal.
这些罗马采石场属于国有，主要依靠奴隶劳动力。它们位于炎热干燥的地方，全部由军队监督。这是可怕的、累垮人的工作。开采大理石后，罗马人将其通过地中海运送，并用它来建造使他们闻名遐迩的宏伟建筑。几个世纪以来一直如此。罗马人建造纪念碑来展示他们的伟大，使用的是来自遥远地方的稀有石头，传达的信息很明确：罗马是永恒的。
Until it wasn't. Starting around the middle of the third century, the Roman Empire got hit by a series of overlapping catastrophes. Each one made the next one worse. This wasn't exactly the fall of Rome. It was more like the stumble. First, there was political chaos. People keep murdering the emperor and then declaring themselves emperor
直到它不再是永恒。从公元三世纪中叶开始，罗马帝国遭遇了一系列相互交织的灾难。每一次灾难都使下一次变得更糟。这不完全是罗马的灭亡。这更像是它的绊倒。首先是政治混乱。人们不断谋杀皇帝，然后宣布自己为皇帝，
far, far away from Rome, and it's very chaotic, and there's no stability at the top. Meanwhile, the empire's neighbors were watching this political instability and they're thinking, hey, there's an opportunity here. Everybody around the outside of the empire thinks this is a great time to try and have a go at taking some land for themselves. You start to get non-Roman peoples trying to get inside the empire. Then a pandemic hit. It was called the Plague of the Cyprian and it was horrific. For almost 20 years, it ripped through the empire. Some scholars now think it was a virus similar to Ebola.
地点远在罗马之外，情况非常混乱，高层毫无稳定性。与此同时，帝国的邻居们看到了这种政治不稳定，心想，嘿，这里有机遇。帝国周边所有的人都认为这是一个尝试为自己夺取一些土地的好时机。你开始看到非罗马人试图进入帝国境内。接着是一场大流行病。被称为西普里安瘟疫，极其恐怖。持续了近20年，肆虐整个帝国。一些学者现在认为这是一种类似于埃博拉的病毒。
And it was killing thousands of people a day for 20 years in seasonal cycles. And then the climate was also changing. The agricultural parts of the empire experienced terrible droughts. The Nile stopped flooding. Crops failed. People starved. Oh, and then there was hyperinflation on top of everything else. And these various crises went on and on for decades.
并且在季节性循环中，连续20年每天杀死成千上万的人。然后气候也在发生变化。帝国的农业区经历了可怕的干旱。尼罗河停止泛滥。农作物绝收。人们挨饿。哦，然后在这一切之上还有恶性通货膨胀。这些各种各样的危机持续了整整几十年。
Needless to say, nobody was really looking after the Roman's magnificent marble buildings during this absolute cluster of a half century, there was a lot of deferred maintenance while people dealt with hemorrhagic fevers and famine and invasion from all sides. Nobody has been replacing broken tiles or polishing the tiled floors or putting the mosaics back together.
不用说，在这半个世纪的绝对混乱中，没有人真正在照看罗马那些宏伟的大理石建筑，当人们应对出血热、饥荒和四面八方的入侵时，有大量的维护被搁置了。没有人去更换破损的瓷砖、打磨铺地砖或把马赛克拼图重新拼凑起来。
The result was that in Rome, there was a lot of beautiful, expensive marble just sitting there, slowly falling apart from neglect. At the same time that was happening, Rome's quarries in Greece, Egypt, and North Africa were becoming really hard to access. Travel and trade was much more dangerous. That meant if you wanted to build something impressive, and the Romans always did, you couldn't
结果是，在罗马，有大量美丽且昂贵的大理石就那样闲置着，在忽视中慢慢破败。与此同时，罗马在希腊、埃及和北非的采石场变得非常难以进入。旅行和贸易变得危险得多。这意味着如果你想建造一些令人印象深刻的东西，而罗马人总是想这么做，你就不能
just order up some new marble. The Romans were in a bind. Their colossal old monuments were falling down, and they couldn't get the material to build new ones. Until finally, one guy connected the dots. He realized that you could use. use those old buildings as raw material to build new stuff. His name was Constantine.
直接订购一些新的大理石。罗马人陷入了困境。他们庞大的旧纪念碑正在倒塌，而他们却无法获得建造新纪念碑的材料。直到最后，一个人把这些线索串联了起来。他意识到你可以使用。利用那些旧建筑作为建造新事物的原材料。他的名字叫君士坦丁。
By the time Constantine kind of comes and unites the empire, everybody is very ready for a savior. Constantine grew up a soldier, and he spent nearly 20 years fighting one civil war after another until finally he controlled the entire empire. Then he proceeded to transform it. He legalized Christianity, for one thing, and most relevant to our story, he launched an enormous wave of construction.
当君士坦丁到来并统一帝国时，每个人都非常渴望一个救世主。君士坦丁作为一名士兵长大，他花了近20年的时间打了一场又一场内战，直到最后他控制了整个帝国。然后他着手改造帝国。首先，他将基督教合法化，而与我们的故事最相关的是，他掀起了规模空前的建设浪潮。
Like every emperor before him, he understood the power of architecture. And so did the people around him. Not long after his bloody ascent to power, the Roman Senate gave him a gift, a huge triumphal arch right next to the Coliseum. I have Constantine's arch tattooed on me, so because it's the quintessential arch. The monument was officially a celebration of Constantine's rule. But Emma says the Senate had its own more self-interested reasons for building the big beautiful arch. It's the kind of thing you do when you have an emperor who kills a lot of people.
就像他之前的每一位皇帝一样，他理解建筑的力量。他周围的人也是如此。在他血腥登上权力宝座后不久，罗马元老院送给他一份礼物：一座紧邻斗兽场的巨大凯旋门。我在身上纹了君士坦丁凯旋门的纹身，因为它是最典型的凯旋门。这座纪念碑官方上是为了庆祝君士坦丁的统治。但埃玛说，元老院建造这座宏伟美丽凯旋门有其自身更具私利的理由。当你有一个杀了很多人的皇帝时，你就会做这种事。
You give him the biggest arch. You give him anything that will make him happy and hopefully not turn his really big successful army against you at any point. The arch was covered in panel. with sculpted scenes on them. But many of those panels weren't originally made for Constantine. They were taken from monuments honoring emperors who lived around 200 years before.
你给他最大的凯旋门。你给他任何能让他高兴的东西，并希望在任何时候都不会把这支庞大且成功的军队调转矛头对准你。凯旋门上覆盖着嵌板。上面刻有雕刻场景。但其中许多嵌板最初并不是为君士坦丁制作的。它们是从大约200年前生活的皇帝的纪念碑上取下来的。
This was partly a matter of practicality because it was hard to get enough new marble to make the arch from scratch. But maybe more importantly, it was a symbolic move because in a narcissistic twist, the images of the old emperors had been reworked to look like Constantine.
这在一定程度上是出于实用性的考虑，因为很难获得足够的新大理石来从头制作凯旋门。但也许更重要的是，这是一个象征性的举动，因为带着一种自恋的扭曲，旧皇帝的形象被重新加工，看起来像是君士坦丁。
sculptor has gone in and subtly reshaped the face because he's got quite a distinctive head, Constantine. So they have made his big square head and put that onto the original. This effectively made it look like Constantine with his big square head was doing all the stuff that past emperors had done, like riding a horse over the bodies of his enemies, or addressing a crowd of troops, or hunting a lion. The idea was to remind people of when Rome was great. To invoke a memory of Rome at its healthiest as its most prosperous.
雕刻师走进去，巧妙地重塑了面部，因为君士坦丁的脑袋相当独特。所以他们做出了他那个巨大的方形脑袋，并把它安到了原作上。这实际上使得看起来像是拥有巨大方形脑袋的君士坦丁在做着过去皇帝所做的一切事情，比如骑马踩过敌人的尸体、向军队发表讲话，或者猎狮。这个想法是为了提醒人们罗马伟大的时期。唤起人们对罗马最健康、最繁荣时期的记忆。
So it is a specific and deliberate choice to make that clear connection back to a kind of lost golden past. Constantine's art was a masterpiece of political messaging, and it was also a turning point in the history of architectural reuse. There has been some debate among scholars
因此，这是一种具体而刻意的选择，旨在与某种失去的黄金时代建立清晰的联系。君士坦丁的艺术是政治信息的杰作，也是建筑重复利用历史上的一个转折点。学者们一直在争论
about whether the repurposing of the panels was artistic or just practical, but a lot of them think it wasn't just recycling to cut costs. It was meant to communicate something about the new political moment. A column pulled out of a pagan temple still has an aura of prestige. A carved panel from Rome's golden age still carries a certain authority. Constantine understood that if you placed those materials in a new context, all of that accumulated meaning could be deployed. in new ways. It was reuse as propaganda. Constantine's reuse also set a new precedent.
关于嵌板的重新利用是出于艺术考虑还是仅仅出于实用，但许多人认为这不仅仅是为了削减成本而进行的回收利用。它是为了传达关于新的政治时刻的一些东西。从异教神庙中拆出来的柱子仍然带有声望的光环。来自罗马黄金时代的雕刻嵌板仍然承载着某种权威。君士坦丁明白，如果你把这些材料放在一个新的语境中，所有那些累积的意义就可以被部署。以新的方式。这就是作为宣传的重复利用。君士坦丁的重复利用也树立了一个新的先例。
Once the emperor himself started pulling apart old monuments to build new ones, it gave permission to the rest of the empire. It became this interesting and legitimate thing to do. And soon this kind of reuse was spreading. People started salvaging old columns and decorative freezes and ornamental stonework. They would pull. pull that material out of old buildings and use it in new construction. And a lot of that new construction was churches. Constantine had legalized Christianity, and now the faith needed a lot of grand new buildings to match its status as a legitimate religion.
一旦皇帝本人开始拆解旧纪念碑来建造新纪念碑，这就为帝国其余的人开了绿灯。这成了一件有趣且合法的事情。很快，这种重复利用就开始蔓延。人们开始打捞旧柱子、装饰性质地饰带和观赏性石雕。他们会拉。把这些材料从旧建筑中拉出来，用于新建设中。其中许多新建设都是教堂。君士坦丁将基督教合法化，现在这个信仰需要大量宏伟的新建筑来与其作为合法宗教的地位相匹配。
Huge basilicas went up across the empire, and they needed marble. Thankfully, there were crumbling pagan temples everywhere, full of the kinds of stone that would make churches look amazing. And it becomes about the power of the church on earth to show that this is God's earth and we can decorate his house with all of the beautiful things. The other thing that supercharged this new wave of architectural reuse was that Constantine had founded a new capital named for himself in Constantinople. And much of the new building in Constantinople involved materials salvaged from other places.
巨大的巴西利卡大教堂在整个帝国拔地而起，它们需要大理石。谢天谢地，到处都是摇摇欲坠的异教神庙，里面充满了能让教堂看起来令人惊叹的石头。这变成了关于地球上教会的力量，以表明这是上帝的土地，我们可以用所有美丽的东西来装饰他的另一个家。推动这股新的建筑重复利用热潮的另一件事是，君士坦丁在君士坦丁堡建立了一个以他自己名字命名的首都。而君士坦丁堡的大部分新建筑都涉及从其他地方打捞来的材料。
When he founds Constantinople, he sweeps around. the empire taking up cool stuff from other places, basically, in order to decorate his new city, much to the stress of everybody else. A lot of people were not thrilled about the old marble temples being pulled apart. Especially in Rome, it sometimes felt like the city was being taken apart piece by piece. Everything that we know about what ordinary people saw about it is that they hated it. People actually rioted. They were so fed up that their neighborhoods were starting to look rampant.
当他建立君士坦丁堡时，他在。整个帝国到处搜刮其他地方的好东西，基本上是为了装饰他的新城市，这让其他人感到非常紧张。许多人对古老大理石神庙被拆散并不感到兴奋。特别是在罗马，有时感觉这座城市正在一块一块地被拆解。我们所知道的关于普通人对此的看法的一切是，他们恨透了。人们甚至发生了骚乱。他们太厌烦了，因为他们的街区开始显得破烂不堪。
shackle and just bad. Like that was a nice building that was in my neighborhood and it had really nice columns on it and now it doesn't have any columns and the roof is falling down. And what nobody's going to do anything about that. They needed the equivalent of a Roman HOA, some enforcer who might keep up the standards of the neighborhood. And eventually, about 50 years after Constantine basically invented this kind of reuse, later emperors were passing laws trying to stop it.
破烂而且糟糕。就像那是我街区里的一栋漂亮的建筑，上面有非常漂亮的柱子，而现在没有任何柱子了，屋顶正在倒塌。而且没有人会对此做任何事情。他们需要一个相当于罗马物业管理委员会（HOA）的机构，某种能够维持街区标准的执法者。最终，在大约君士坦丁基本上发明这种重复利用的50年后，后来的皇帝通过法律试图阻止它。
If you were caught stealing stone from buildings, you could be fined. But the laws were pretty toothless, and it kept happening anyway. And this tension never really went away. There were the people who wanted to preserve the old buildings. And then there were the people who wanted to strip them for parts. In fact, that tension eventually became embedded in the word that we use for the practice. The term spolia was coined during the Renaissance, when researchers, of the time had rediscovered classical Rome and fallen in love with it.
如果你被抓到从建筑物中偷石头，你可能会被罚款。但这些法律相当无牙，而且这种事情还是不断发生。这种紧张关系从未真正消失。有一部分人想要保护旧建筑。还有一部分人想要剥离它们的零件。事实上，这种紧张关系最终融入了我们用来形容这种做法的词汇中。术语spolia是在文艺复兴时期创造的，当时的研究人员
And when they noticed that beautiful ancient Roman stonework had been salvaged and then wedged into medieval church walls, they were disgusted. It looked to them like the church had pillaged the ancient world. They coined the word spolia from the Latin for the spoils of war. To describe this process, to make it into a process of war of almost attack on these old buildings. The use of Spolia starts as a renaissance moral judgment on what has happened. But over time, the term lost its moral sting. And now in academic writing, it is just used as a neutral descriptor. Spolia outlived the empire that made it famous.
当时的学者重新发现了古典罗马并深深爱上了它。当他们注意到美丽的古罗马石雕被抢救出来并塞进中世纪的教堂墙壁时，他们感到恶心。在他们看来，这就像是教会掠夺了古代世界。他们从拉丁语中创造了“spolia”一词，意为战利品。用来描述这个过程，将其变成一个战争的过程，几乎是对这些旧建筑的攻击。Spolia的使用始于文艺复兴时期对所发生事情的道德判断。但随着时间的推移，这个词失去了它的道德刺痛感。现在在学术写作中，它只被用作一个中性的描述词。Spolia的寿命超过了使其闻名的帝国。
Wherever the Romans built stuff, later civilizations found their materials and put them to new uses. Roman tiles showed up in medieval churches in England. Charlemagne installed Roman stonework in the chapel in his palace. And across the Islamic world, mosques were built with columns salvaged from Roman temples. But Spolia is really just one expression of a much older and more universal human instinct to reuse. After the Second World War, for example, when European cities lay in ruins, people picked through the rubble and used what they found to rebuild. That wasn't really spolia because it wasn't about symbolism.
无论罗马人在哪里建造东西，后来的文明都会找到他们的材料并将其用于新的用途。罗马瓷砖出现在英格兰的中世纪教堂中。查理曼大帝在他的宫殿小教堂里安装了罗马石雕。在整个伊斯兰世界，清真寺是用从罗马神庙中打捞出来的柱子建造的。但Spolia其实只是人类更古老、更普遍的重复利用本能的一种表达。例如，第二次世界大战后，当欧洲城市成了一片废墟时，人们在瓦砾中挑选并利用他们发现的东西进行重建。那其实不是spolia，因为它与象征意义无关。
It was just necessity. But still, the underlying logic was the same. For most of human history, reuse wasn't some special thing. It was just how people built. But it's not how people build anymore. That's when we come back. Today, the vast majority of construction involves demolishing what's already there and starting from scratch, with all new materials that are uniform and predictable,
那只是出于必需。但尽管如此，其背后的逻辑是一样的。在人类历史的大部分时间里，重复利用并不是什么特殊的事情。这只是人们建造的方式。但这已经不是人们现在的建造方式了。这就是我们回归的时候。今天，绝大多数建筑都涉及到拆除现有的东西并从头开始，使用全新、统一且可预测的材料，
with no history and no variability. It's often cheaper and more efficient than reusing the old stuff. But now, a growing number of architects and researchers think that reuse is a practice we need to relearn. Because it turns out that making everything from scratch with raw materials is something the planet can't sustain. As we look into the future,
没有历史，也没有可变性。它通常比重复利用旧东西更便宜、更高效。但现在，越来越多的建筑师和研究人员认为，重复利用是我们必须重新学习的一种做法。因为事实证明，用原材料从头制造一切是地球无法承受的。当我们展望未来时，
we're not going to be in an extract and throw away world. This is Kate Semenon, a professor of architecture at the University of Washington. I mean, by requirement, we're going to need to reuse the things that we have made previously. Otherwise, ultimately, we would run out. The labor and fuel expended in creating even a single brick are enormous. And Kate says that it's worth sitting with what it actually takes to make something new. So in order to make a brick, you have to excavate the clay material from the earth.
我们将不再处于一个开采和抛弃的世界。这是华盛顿大学建筑学教授凯特·西门农（Kate Simonen）。我的意思是，根据要求，我们需要重复利用我们以前制造的东西。否则，最终我们会耗尽。制造哪怕一块砖所消耗的劳动力和燃料都是巨大的。凯特说，值得坐下来好好想想制造一样新东西到底需要付出什么。所以在制作一块砖时，你必须从地球上开采黏土材料。
And in doing that, you're using an excavator that's burning deep. And so as you're burning that diesel, emissions go up into the atmosphere. So that's step one, just digging the clay out of the ground. Then you have to shape it. And that's often done with a machine. And that machine might be using electricity, making that electricity has emissions. Then the brick needs to be cured. And that usually means burning natural gas to fire the kiln.
在这样做时，你会使用一台深度燃烧的挖掘机。因此，当你燃烧柴油时，排放物就会进入大气层。所以这是第一步，仅仅是从地下挖出黏土。然后你必须塑造它。这通常是由机器完成的。那台机器可能会使用电力，而产生这种电力会有排放。然后这块砖需要固化。这通常意味着燃烧天然气来烧窑。
And that natural gas then releases emissions into the atmosphere. And finally, you have to transport the brick to wherever it's needed, which requires a truck or a train. train or an airplane. And that then is also, again, likely burning diesel, which releases emissions. Now consider every brick, every steel beam, every panel of drywall, and every pane of glass in every building in the world. There's just an enormous amount of materials and labor and what's called embodied carbon in
然后这些天然气就会向大气中释放排放物。最后，你必须把这块砖运输到任何需要它的地方，这需要卡车、火车。或飞机。然后，这也同样可能会燃烧柴油，从而释放排放物。现在想想世界上每栋建筑中的每一块砖、每一根钢梁、每一块干墙板和每一块玻璃。有大量的材料、劳动力以及所谓的隐含碳存在于
the built environment. Which is why a growing number of architects and engineers argued that we basically need to practice spolia at scale. And that sounds like a great idea, but it's actually very hard to do. When you salvage something like an old steel beam, it's hard to know exactly what you've got, like what it's actually made of and what loads it can carry. There is no reliable supply chain for reclaimed materials, at least not at the scale we really need.
建筑环境中。这就是为什么越来越多的建筑师和工程师认为，我们基本上需要在规模上实践spolia。这听起来是个好主意，但实际上很难做到。当你打捞像旧钢梁这样的东西时，很难确切知道你得到了什么，比如它到底是用什么材料制成的，能承受什么荷载。回收材料没有可靠的供应链，至少在我们真正需要的规模上没有。
And most buildings aren't designed to be taken apart. It takes a lot of time and effort to deconstruct an old building piece by piece so that the parts can be used again. How we make buildings today has an influence on how easy they will be to take a part in the future. And not that many building owners today are asking their design teams to make it easy to tear down my building in 60 to 80 years. That's not really their top priority. In other words, it's hard to get out of that emperor mindset that buildings must last forever. There are some traditions that better understand a building's transience. For example, Japanese temples used to be built without nails or screws.
而且大多数建筑都不是为了被拆解而设计的。把一栋旧建筑一块一块地拆解以使零件可以再次使用，需要花费大量的时间和精力。我们今天建造建筑物的方式会影响它们未来拆解的容易程度。如今并没有那么多的建筑业主要求他们的设计团队让我的建筑在60到80年后更容易拆除。这并不是他们的首要任务。换句话说，很难摆脱那种建筑必须永存的皇帝心态。有一些传统更好地理解了建筑的短暂性。例如，日本寺庙过去常常不用钉子或螺丝建造。
Instead, they were supported by interlocking wooden joints so that they could be taken apart and reassembled. And there are modern examples, too, like the Olympic Village during the 2024 Paris Games that was designed. to be converted to housing after the competition. So there are buildings here and there being designed with their next life in mind. I asked Kate what she thought about the Roman connection, how they took their crumbling buildings and used them as raw materials for something new. I think those buildings actually had fallen apart. You know, they were the debris of previous civilizations.
相反，它们由互锁的木质接头支撑，以便可以拆卸和重新组装。也有现代的例子，比如2024年巴黎奥运会期间的奥运村，它的设计目标就是在比赛结束后改造成住房。因此，这里和那里都有一些在设计时就考虑了其下一个生命周期的建筑。我问凯特她对罗马连接的看法，他们如何将崩塌的建筑用作新事物的原材料。我认为那些建筑其实已经倒塌了。你知道的，它们是前代文明的残骸。
And so ultimately, our lives will be the debris for other civilizations. There are a lot of ways to think about what makes building materials valuable. Kate thinks about it in terms of scarcity. The earth is finite. There's not an endless amount of clay, sand, and stone. We have to be careful not to exhaust the materials we have. The Roman emperors thought about value in terms of prestige. Placing old materials in new contexts allowed them to communicate something about continuity and power.
因此，归根结底，我们的生活将成为其他文明的残骸。有很多方法可以思考是什么让建筑材料变得有价值。凯特从稀缺性的角度来考虑这个问题。地球是有限的。黏土、沙子和石头的数量并不是无穷无尽的。我们必须小心，不要耗尽我们拥有的材料。罗马皇帝从声望的角度来思考价值。将旧材料置于新的语境中使他们能够传达关于连续性和权力的信息。
And the residents of Granby in South Liverpool measured value in a different way. They cared about the history of their neighborhood. And when they worked with Lewis Jones and the team at Assemble, they didn't just see old and dilapidated houses. They saw the raw materials for something new. Granby Rock, the product they made from the neighborhood's debris, was a way of insisting that the community still had worth. It was important to put these things into the houses,
利物浦南部格兰比的居民以另一种方式衡量价值。他们关心他们街区的历史。当他们与路易斯·琼斯和Assemble团队合作时，他们看到的不仅仅是破旧的老房子。他们看到了创造新事物的原材料。“格兰比岩”，这个他们用街区废墟制造的产品，是一种坚持认为这个社区仍然具有价值的方式。把这些东西放进房子里很重要，
that would express the, you know, yeah, love and care and attention that had gone into renovating them. But since the early days of the Granby project, Lewis and his collaborators have started thinking much more about reuse in the context of climate change. The Granby Workshop didn't close when the renovation was finished. Instead, it grew into something bigger, a manufacturing studio in the neighborhood that's still running today. It produces architectural tiles and ceramics out of recycled materials. They fire these tiles at lower temperatures to reduce their environmental footprint, and they use electric kilns. So what started as spolia in the oldest sense has evolved into something more like what Kate Semenin advocates for. The workshop now helps other projects turn their construction debris into new building materials.
这将表达出，你知道的，是的，对翻新这些房子所投入的爱、关怀和关注。但自从格兰比项目的早期阶段以来，路易斯和他的合作者开始更多地从气候变化的背景来思考重复利用。当翻新完成时，格兰比工作室并没有关闭。相反，它发展成了更大的东西，一个至今仍在运营的街区制造工作室。它用回收材料生产建筑瓷砖和陶瓷。他们以较低的温度烧制这些瓷砖以减少环境足迹，并且他们使用电窑。因此，最初在最古老意义上的spolia已经演变成类似于凯特·西门农所倡导的东西。该工作室现在帮助其他项目将其建筑废料变成新的建筑材料。
It's reuse that involves symbolism, but it's also a practical recognition that we can't keep extracting raw materials forever. Every project always starts with trying to understand what's already there and how to be really resourceful. And so reuse is a big, big part of that. I asked Lewis what Granby looks like today. More than a decade after Assembly joined with the community land trust to renovate the first houses. Granby today still very much has the same spirit. I think it had, you know, when I first visited 15-odd years ago, there's still a kind of sense of wildness there.
这是一种涉及象征意义的重复利用，但它也是一种实用的认可，即我们不能永远开采原材料。每个项目总是从试图理解已经存在的东西以及如何真正足智多谋开始的。因此，重复利用是其中非常非常重要的一部分。我问路易斯今天的格兰比是什么样子的。在Assemble加入社区土地信托翻新第一批房子十多年后，今天的格兰比仍然很有那种精神。我认为它有，你知道的，当我15年前第一次来访时，那里仍然有一种野性。
You know, there's still, like, furniture on the street, there's plants in the pavement, there's the odd painting on the wall, whatever it is. But obviously, you know, amongst that, there are a lot more people living now. Lewis described kids playing on the streets, where not too long ago every house had one of those signs. The ones that said all items of value have been removed from this property. Those signs were, of course, wrong. The materials of the past are never worthless.
你知道的，街上仍然有家具，路面上有植物，墙上有奇怪的画，不管是什么。但显然，你知道的，在这其中，现在有更多的人住在那里了。路易斯描述了孩子们在街上玩耍的情景，不久前，每栋房子都挂着那些牌子。那些写着“本物业所有有价值的物品均已被搬走”的牌子。这些牌子当然是错的。过去的材料永远不是一文不值的。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Delaney Hall and edited by Emmett Fitzgerald, mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. Fact-checking by Sona Avakian. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kurt Colsted is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Burupé, Jason DeLeon, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashamadon, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Talon and Rain Stradley, and Me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
本周的《99% Invisible》由德兰妮·霍尔制作，埃姆·菲茨杰拉德剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔创作。索娜·阿瓦基安负责事实核查。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特德是我们的数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·布鲁佩、杰森·德莱昂、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·莱、拉沙马顿、乔·罗森伯格、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、塔隆和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马斯。99% Invisible的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。
We are a part of the Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our own Discord server. there's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于奥克兰美丽的住宅区北面六个街区的潘多拉大楼。在加利福尼亚州奥克兰。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。在那上面有一个链接，还有 99PI 过去每一集的链接，网址是 99PI.org。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。